Like what is your stance on like gay
Muslims?
>> Is what you're doing a sin? Yes, I will
never take that away and say to you,
"No, I'm not going to sugar my
religion." However, a person who bows
down to an idol is million times worse
than what you're doing.
>> Dear brothers and sisters, as we watch
what is unfolding today in we have to
understand that opposition is counting
on us to lose attention, to become
fatigued, and to move on with the new
cycle. And just as we can't allow them
to dictate our attention, we also can't
allow them to dictate the pace of our
solidarity. [music] And part of that
solidarity is going to be there to
rebuild Gaza short-term, long-term. I am
proud to give my support, my word of
support to trusted brothers and sisters
in the United Kingdom that have started
awak that have started an endowment to
make sure inshallah that we're there for
the long run. It's going to be long term
and we will not forget our cause and we
will not forget the cause of and we will
not forget our brothers and sisters.
[music]
>> Hello sis. Are you okay? You Muslim?
>> Yes I am actually.
>> Alhamdulillah. How long?
>> A couple of years. I've not been I've
fallen off a little. I'm on and off now.
follow. Trust me, I've had my days as
well.
>> It's all learning. It's all learning.
Lovely to meet you. I've seen you on
>> online and so on.
>> How are you?
>> What was What was your before, sister?
>> Um, so my so my mom is Bangladeshi, my
dad's Jamaican. My mom's side of the
family is Muslim. My grandma
raised my mom and like the their
siblings with or her siblings, sorry,
with Islam. And then they kind of all
were westernized and kind of rejected
the religion. I wasn't raised with it.
Um, and I always felt that sense of like
I needed some kind of direction or
something growing up and um I think as a
teenager and then getting into like a
young teenager, I was like quite
troubled and you know
>> Yeah, me too. I was
>> you know I was like I was a naughty kid
and
>> as I got older and like learned more
lessons through life I realized that and
like I I knew that I wanted religion in
my life but I didn't necessarily knew
that it like know it was going to be
Islam. And then as I learned more about
it and met more people who were like
from Bangladesh as well and like oh you
know like Islam's amazing like taught me
all these things about it and I realized
that a lot of the things in the Quran
like aligned with a lot of things I
believed in my life anyways and like a
lot of things I wanted from my life and
and my morals and stuff. So it was kind
of like a natural
>> transition. Exactly. And um and yeah, I
took it like when I started, I took it
really seriously. And I don't think I
realized like how much of a commitment
it is. Like it really takes so much to
to do it. But
>> I think you know what it is. I don't
think the commitment is great.
>> I think the pressure externally makes
the commitment bigger than it is. Like
if you look at the religion of the Jews,
oh you don't know. Should I tell you
something? They have 600 and something
13 laws. It's so difficult. If you look
at Judaism, you will say Islam is a
walking apart because we have external
pressures. And as as women as well,
you've got the beauty industry, how to
look, what to wear, and there's so much
more stigma on you guys. It's even
harder. That's the reason why we see an
influx of women coming to Islam because
liberating yourself from the beauty.
Now, look, of course, every woman like
the trial for the Did you ever used to
wear hijab?
>> I did. I I actually did.
when I first started I was with someone
at the time who was also Muslim as well.
So I I wanted to take it a bit more
seriously, you know, as a as a couple,
you know, like for that person like
represent him as, you know, as a proper
Muslim woman. And even finding like even
that transition from wearing hijab, like
it made me realize in myself how much
pressure I put on myself outside of just
my face, of my beauty, and how much I
relied on my hair and I relied on my
body and what I wore and things like
that. And I learned so much about myself
and it was like it was almost upsetting
at first. I remember putting on hijab
the first time in the in the bathroom
and I I cried like I cried so much cuz I
realized how much pressure I put on
everything outside and like I I don't
wear it now at the moment and
>> No problem. I' I think I've taken like
that that's never left me like I I know
that in myself that I've
>> So just so I understand. So what's your
name?
>> Um Chen Sister Chen. Sister Chen, do you
know how to pray? I I I did I did.
>> This is for you. It's a guided prayer,
man. But I just want to explore
something. So you said that when you put
the hijab on, you realize the external
pressure of your hair and your said your
body or something like that.
>> Yeah. Like do you mean do you mean when
you put the hijab on you realized how
much I'm just trying to understand. Do
you mean like how much you relied on
looking pretty? Is that what you meant
or did I misunderstand?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think I I realized how
much I relied on my hair and what I wore
in my body to feel pretty, to feel
beautiful,
>> feel validated,
>> to feel read a book. It's called Beauty
Sick
>> and there's a book called Girls on Edge.
>> Now, because what studies are showing is
that women have never been more unhappy.
>> Yeah.
>> And this goes back to that because for
example, the standards are so high in
the book that I'm reading, beauty sick,
and I'm reading this book uh called uh
Girls on Edge. It's just an influx of
anti-depressants. Why? Because number
one, women have to be led. Allah has
made us that the man is the leader and a
woman looks for that. You can't you you
wouldn't deny that. You look for in a
man that he's the leader.
>> Yeah. Like definitely in a person look
for someone. So
>> Exactly. Someone that leads, somebody
that makes decisions. Of course, this
doesn't mean you don't have a decision-m
factor, but he's the man. You get what
I'm trying to say?
>> Exactly. Because the the feminine is a
flow. It needs that certain man to be
like, you know what, I got this. Do you
get what I'm trying to say? And a woman
appreciate that. Today, sadly, we have
men that are not men. they become more
feminine than women. [laughter] That's
that's that's that's one of the issue we
have. Yes. So, so, so, so I can relate
to you because in the book there was a
girl. So, this woman was doing a study.
>> It's called beauty sick for a reason.
It's talking about the sickness of
beauty amongst young teenagers. Some of
them would starve theirself and have a
yoga every 4 hours not to pass out to
have the perfect body.
>> These pressures are so bad. She said
that at one point she wanted to stop the
study of how disturbed she got. speaking
to these young girls who were like I
wish I don't have to focus on my looks
that I can spend more time with my
family studying and doing better things.
So the pressure is so immense. So that's
the reason why when you said for example
in Islam it comes across as if Islam is
restricting you but rather the external
pressures are so big that when you put
the hijab on you was like wow and
because what that does is obviously cuz
to a man we we we are visual creatures.
When we see a woman in a hijab in a body
we're like okay if if I'm if I have bad
intentions I'm like okay she's not about
that life. And then what happens is the
attention drops. But it's good because
you know why the attention is not
retention. So then you are open because
that's the reason why Allah in the Quran
if you look at it for example there's a
verse which really makes it amazes me.
It says
with hardship comes ease and then Allah
repeats the statement. Did Allah forget?
No. With hardship comes ease. Now if
with hardship comes ease the opposite
has to be true. With ease comes
>> good. So what happens is this sister And
this goes for both men and women. I say
to brothers, if you don't lower your
gaze.
>> Yeah. Because I'm talking to you out of
respect. I don't want to talk to you
like this. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? But lowering the gaze, looking at
not looking at haram.
>> Looking at a woman who's dressed up
inappropriately is the most easiest
thing man can do. All it takes is a
glance.
>> However, to lower your gaze is hard. But
the ease that will follow and that will
protect you from not sexual objects
woman not falling into z. So that's why
Allah says with hardship comes ease.
meaning do the hardship now you will see
the benefits of ease. So it comes to the
hijab as well. When you wear the hijab,
it's damn difficult. We as men could
never understand that. That's why we
salute you guys. Yeah. And your journey
is still there. Alhamdulillah. And and a
hijab is not a covering over the head.
>> Modesty, it starts from everywhere. Do
you get it? So the hijab is hard, but
the trials, it protects you from all
those f boys, what you want to call
them. Sorry, I'm I'm a sorry. Yeah. It
protects you as a barrier to all of
those idiots. And when you have your
guard, when the right one comes, then
you understand and appreciate what it
does for you. But like I said before,
sister, everyone has their journey.
Alhamdulillah. Yeah. May Allah make it
easy for you. Subhan Allah. And like I
said, salah is the main thing. I always
say, Subhan Allah. Salah is the main
thing. Salah is the h of Allah. Subhan
Allah. So may Allah make it easy for
you. Do you have any questions for me?
Anything that you would like to
No, that's all right. I just wanted to
like kind of just have a chat really.
I've just seen you online so much. So I
just feel like it be nice. anything on
your mind like for example when it comes
to any misconceptions about Islam
>> anything that I can help you with
>> what's so like what's the opinion on
>> like what is your stance on like gay
Muslims
>> he believes I there's a video of me on
Tik Tok
>> yeah or gay lesbian
>> yeah I was in we was in I was in
Leicester Square was a gay guy so
>> let me give you a Quran he's like nah
nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah
n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n
nah not for me. Yeah, sorry I did accent
as well. Yeah, n not for me. Yeah, I was
like listen mate it's for everyone. He
actually thought we're like Christians.
I went to I went to California. Yeah.
And there was Christians on campus. They
were dooming people to hell. You're
going to hell. You're going to burn. And
I was like, what the hell is he on
about? Mercy and hope is the
fundamentals of Islam. Why does every
single verse in the chapter of the Quran
except one chapter in Surah Toba, Allah
says Allah is the most merciful, very
merciful. Allah says, "My mercy
outweighs my anger." Cuz losing hope is
one of the most harmful things ever. So
to me, I always say to I say to the gay
guy, you can be a Muslim. He goes, "No."
I said, "What do you mean no?" I said,
"Listen, even if you are acting upon it,
as long as you don't say it's halal."
You say it's halal, you're in trouble
cuz Allah said it's haram. But if you
are acting upon the deed and you know it
is a sin, what's the difference between
you and a man who goes and sleeps around
which is wrong? You're still a Muslim.
That's the reason why I can remember at
the time of the prophet there was a
companion a sahaba a companion of the
prophet Muhammad who fought in the wars
with him the battle of bad the battle of
maybe the battle of kanda
>> he used to drink alcohol
>> in imagine in front of the prophet not
but
>> and they used to frog him so there was a
punishment of frog like 60 frogs yeah
>> once and he was doing this again they'll
keep frogging him in public one day one
of the companions said may Allah curse
you now you would expect the prophet to
say yeah may Allah curse him he was so
angry he went to the compan said don't
say that to him for he loves Allah and
his messenger now in today's time we
think he drinks in front of the prophet
no the prophet sallallaihi wasallam saw
mercy he said the act is wrong but we
never say Allah hates him because Allah
his repentance in the sight of Allah
might be more heavier than a man who's a
righteous person who saysar this is what
we don't understand we judge people and
say oh this person is this person that
now do we judge people in a parent? Of
course we do. If I see a sister dressed
up in a mini skirt or I see a brother
who's drinking alcohol, I'm going to
judge and say that's haram. That's
haram. Yes. However, the sinful judges
what? Oh, she dressed up in a skirt. She
probably sleeps around. That's haram.
Oh, he's got a earring. He's probably a
thief.
>> Excuse me. How did you go from the
judgment from the apparent to the
judgment of the heart?
>> That is not allowed. That's where we
don't say only God can judge me too bad.
Okay. So that's the difference, sister.
So like I said before, no one can look
at you and this is what I hate. Oh, she
doesn't wear hijab. Okay, she's probably
Excuse me. Who are you to come and say
just cuz she's struggling with
something? I know or heard of stories of
sisters who wear hijab and they do
madness.
>> Madness. Yes. However, I do not want
this I know this going to be taken as I
don't want this to be taken as if oh cuz
there's another extreme. Oh, I don't
wear the hijab. No, no, hold on a
second. True. But this doesn't mean it
gives you a validation of yeah but I
don't wear the hijab. Okay, I know
sisters who wear the hijab and they
don't do those sins. So we should always
excel ourself. But one thing is don't
judge. [music] Don't judge a sister and
say she's in a kabi. She must be so
pious. You don't know nothing about her.
Neither look at a sister and say she
doesn't wear hijab she must be. No no no
no no no. So that's why Islam has come
for us to purify our hearts and not be
oh who's doing what? You know. So like I
said sister may Allah preserve and
strengthen you. We do believe gays and
lesbians can be Muslims even if they're
doing the act as long as they don't come
and say no no this is permissible. That
is the only thing.
>> Okay. Amazing. Oh, that's really good to
know cuz I'm I'm actually dating a woman
at the moment.
And so it's something that I've like
thought about in myself and you know
it's it's a conflict naturally that you
have cuz I know like in my heart I'm a
Muslim and like you know even like
yesterday I was like praying cuz I had
some like hardships and I needed a bit
of guidance and like you know help from
Allah like subhan Allah
>> and um and yeah and it's something I
thought about cuz it's like if we did
you know
>> get older and have kids and things like
I want to raise my children with like
with like Muslim morals and you know
Muslim values, Muslim morals and um any
obviously just being
>> gay as well having those morals. Like to
some people it might sound mad
>> like people might even not even expect
this from me cuz people I don't know
what perception they have. They think
I'm some kind of like yeah you're doomed
to hell sister we're going to start. No
cuz you know why if you genuinely
understand Islam now is what you're
doing a sin yes I will never take that
away and say to you no I'm not going to
sugar my religion. However
>> a person who bows down to an idol is
million times worse than what you're
doing. That's shik. People mis they they
misunderstand things. to ask Shik is the
worst thing. However,
>> have you was you always like this? Did
you become like this? Is there a factor
just and it's personally you don't need
to answer
>> okay
>> that's fine you don't need to answer but
what I would say is this sister yeah is
that look there was one guy I met his
name was Hussein he's I think he's from
Birmingham he's gay
>> he came to speak I sat with him and I
spoke with him he said something really
profound to me he said you know what Ali
he goes I'm gay however he goes I don't
act on it I said okay I said so so how
do you go about it cuz it's like to me I
can get married
>> you kept me like how do you go about it
and he said something to him said you
know what I have my trust in Allah he
goes if If you think about it, married
couples, they are so busy with their
marital affairs and kids and that they
don't even get time to spend time with
Allah. He goes, I use that by having
that relationship with Allah personally.
And sister says this, if you ever leave
something for the sake of Allah, Allah
will you see sister there was I think it
was Ibia the scholar. He said paradise
is in my heart. Throw me in prisons.
Throw me wherever you like. If Jenna is
here,
>> nothing matters. When you have that
relationship with Allah and get closer
to him, sister, you see these worldly
desires.
>> They slowly they leave you. And then you
have that sweetness of relationship with
Allah subhanaa tala. Sometimes wah I'll
be honest with you, sometimes there
scholars who never got married. And you
think to yourself, but what men visual
creatures all your life you didn't get
married. Allah gives you the sweetness
of im that you don't need anybody. Not
there's nothing wrong with that getting
married. So I would say sister as long
as you acknowledge it's wrong. As long
as you acknowledge it requires change,
>> just have goals. You know what? Yes,
what I'm doing is wrong. I do need a
companion in my life. W Allah says in
the Quran, if you fear me, I will give
you a way out from places you can never
imagine. Wall says, "I've been in
situations, it's like I'm at a dead
road. It's like a cliff." And you know
what I do sometimes? I sometimes sit
down and I write down. You know what I
write down? I I say I know Allah is
going to get me out of this mess, but
I'm going to start guessing how Allah is
going to do it. So I start writing down
option one, Allah's going to do this,
option two. So in my head, I'm thinking
right means
Allah gets me out of that situation and
I would not think of a million years.
The way he got me out of it was nothing
to do with the list.
>> Something completely came from nowhere.
And Allah just shows you if you fear me
and if you love me and I come first in
your life life I will take you out from
any mess from places you can ever
imagine. So anytime just bear that in
mind inshallah and like I said before
you're a Muslim never take that identity
from you. Don't let any Muslim ever tell
you you're not a Muslim. You are a
Muslim and whatever said sister
alhamdulillah may Allah make it easy for
you inshallah. We all go through
different trials and tribulations. Have
repentance on your tongue. Ask Allah for
guidance inshallah and may Allah make it
easy for you.
>> I do have one more question sister. Um,
so my ex partner, a man, he was a reaver
as well.
>> So you was
>> so you was heterosexual.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like both. Both. I've always
been in between.
>> Okay. So there's a possibility to go
back to that
>> pos. Yeah. I guess we're going to make
we're going to make
find a good Muslim man.
>> But that's the thing. So I thought I did
I I So I met a Muslim man. He was
actually a rever as well, which kind of
helped encourage me, you know, um take
my harder also. Maybe a bit earlier than
I think I was ready for, but either way
I did, like, alhamdulillah. And but this
man, he wasn't a good man. He, you know,
he was a drug dealer. He was abusive. He
hit me. He beat me. He his exes, his
things like that. And I in that
situation for such a while, but but you
know, he he went to Jama every Friday
like and he did everything. He he took
drugs. He like he sometimes drank, but
you know, and but he then would like
almost, you know, go go Jamaa every
Friday and think that it's a race.
everything that he's done every week,
you know, every day that he's done, the
drug dealing that he does, the drinking
that that he does, the the the physical
harm that he does and the emotional
abuse and stuff. And it's like, what
what do you I don't know what's your
opinion on that, your stance on that?
>> I would say this, sister. If in his mind
he's saying, I'm going to do these acts
and I don't repent for it, I don't
dislike it, I'm happy doing it, I'll go
and it will wipe it out. There's there's
there's truths to it to an element. When
you violate the laws of Allah subhana wa
tala, repentance is required. There's
the scholars say there are three
conditions for repentance. You stop the
sin, you try not go to back to the sin,
and you hate the sin. However, if you
violate the rights of someone when he
was hitting you, that's unacceptable.
Now, he needs to ask the forgiveness
from you for hitting you. So, to me, if
he is someone like a sinner, if he came
to me and said, "I've done that." I
would say the same thing. Look, you're
wrong for doing that, but don't despel
Allah's mercy cuz there was a man who
killed 99 people. He went to a monk and
he said, "Would Allah forgive me?" He
said, "No." He said, "I'm going to kill
you, too." He killed him. Yes. He killed
that man as well cuz he lost hope until
he went to another person and he said,
"Go to this land and in this land you
will find mercy." On his way to the
land, he dies. Have you heard the story?
Check this out. Says, "Look at Allah's
mercy." It's a hadith. On the way to the
land, he dies. The angel of wrath and
the angel of mercy come and they're
debating one another. We're taking him
to hellfire because he killed 100
people. The angel of mercy. No, but he
was on the land to the repentance.
Some scholars say, you know what the
angels came and said? They said, okay,
let's measure the distance. Was he
closer to the land of repentance or
didn't land yet?
>> They say that Allah shifted the earth so
he seems closer. So Allah's mercy, you
know what that shows you? Allah says in
the Quran, "What will I get out of
punishing you?" We don't believe in a
God of wrath like Allah wants to th
hellfire. Allah had so much mercy on him
that he shifted the land so he can
repent. So the question is this. If he
came to me, I'll say the same to him.
Brother, what you're doing is wrong.
It's in your wife. It's not permissible.
Yes. The prophet is the best of mankind.
He actually warned against a female
companion who wanted to get married to a
certain companion. He said that man, he
carries a stick on his back. Don't marry
him. Yeah. So the question is what
sister, I would tell him, don't despair
Allah's mercy. You can change. However,
if he's somebody who thinks I'm going to
go do this, this and I'm going to go,
you're not following Allah. So, what I
would say, sister, would you think,
sorry, do you think that's what? Cuz
sometimes certain lesbians,
they have a trauma with so many men,
they actually say, you know what, I just
don't want these beings in my life. They
hate it. It happens. Like,
>> happens. It happens. I've seen it.
>> Do you think that played a role?
>> Um, no. And not in this, not in this
occasion. Um, but I've seen it. So this
how did you go from heterosexuality to
that?
>> Was it was it something you was like
because because you was heterosexual
before
>> what made you say okay hold on a second
I want to explore this avenue.
>> Um I mean I was with a woman before I
was with this guy I was the move
initially and then the woman before
that.
>> Yeah. Like I've kind of gone back and
forth in in all honesty over the years.
So I wouldn't really say necessarily it
was the trauma from him that turned me
to women cuz I've dated men after him
regardless and I took time to myself
dated people more casually things like
that and this is just someone that I you
know were became friends with and got to
know more and like we feel and developed
a connection in our own kind of way. So
I wouldn't say it was necessarily
because of the trauma.
>> Let me ask you a question.
>> Yeah.
>> Imagine you are cuz you know when you
married him how it was. Um yeah, let's
let's let's let's ignore for the sake
what how he abused you. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> If he was a good man when you was with
him, how was how was it before he went
became like that. Did you see that
potential of okay this can work he's
treating me well? Cuz in the beginning
they're usually good.
>> Yeah.
>> So in that moment did you see h this is
something that I could live with?
>> Uh slightly but I think also my judgment
with it was misguided. I think what I
what I thought from him I was getting in
terms of leadership or protection or
guidance like you know or someone like
provide like being a provider what I he
wasn't there he well at first I thought
that he like he was but not in a way
that you know I would accept or I should
have accepted like I essentially you
know he was just like had cash flowing
and you know we were going here and
going there so I thought oh like that's
what my life could look like or that's
what my life could be. So I thought that
that in my understanding of what a good
man would have been before I found Islam
like I that was what my understanding of
a good man would have been someone
before.
>> So at that moment was he was he was he
good
>> at that moment? Yeah. And then quite
quickly it turned to not being
>> so he was a protector and provider
>> I would say more provider than protector
he looks like yeah he has to protect
himself we need to protect himself from
himself or you yeah so doesn't
understand. So okay I would say sister
look if that's happened
>> I think wallah I'll be honest with you
sister I genuinely believe you can find
a good man that will look after you but
you know what that comes with that comes
with a sacrifice
>> if you believe in Allah and his
messenger sacrifice required if you say
oh Allah that I know this is a sin I
repent for it and I want to change my
ways to the better and I believe do you
agree that Allah controls the entire
earth every atom you know when a rain
drops how it will drop where it will
drop how it will splatter
>> that creat creator can find you a
husband. That creator can find you a
husband. So I would say sister, Allah
will want to see the sacrifice you want
to do for him, not with that condition.
We worship Allah unconditionally. So do
it saying Allah not that I want a
husband, I'm doing it for you. And if it
comes with a husband, it's a bonus. So I
would say explore inshallah.
>> Okay. May Allah bless you. Anything else
I can help you?
>> No. Thank you.
>> May Allah bless you. Love is speaking to
you sister. May Allah bless you. Protect
you. Don't forget you are a Muslim.
Don't let anyone take that away from
you. You got the mat. You haven't got
the mat.
>> Perfect. Take care, sister. May Allah
bless you. So guys, Subhan Allah, that
was a very very powerful Subhan Allah.
I'll be honest with you. Subhan Allah.
These these are the people, Subhan
Allah, that we need to give hope. A lot
of people are judgmental. They judge the
judgments and this and that. Wallah, let
me tell you something. Her being a
Muslim, acknowledging it's a sin,
getting close to Allah, knowing she's a
Muslim is the main thing. So, Subhan
Allah, we should always have hope uh in
Allah subhanaa tala's mercy. And believe
me, there are people out there who are
doing more mad stuff. Subhan Allah. So
please make dua for our sister Chen
inshah.